Ich möchte dir jetzt die wichtigsten Werkzeuge die wir
benötigen, vorstellen.
Wir fangen an mit der Zeichenfeder,
die findest du hier im oberen Bereich.
Mit dieser Zeichenfeder kannst du Linien und Kurven
zeichnen.
Und das probieren wir jetzt gleich einmal aus.
Klick also auf die Zeichenfeder,
dann geh auf dein Plattpapier und setze deinen ersten
Punkt, indem du da raufklickst.
Wenn Du jetzt ein zweites Mal klickst,
entsteht eine Linie zwischen diesen beiden Punkten.
Und nach und nach entsteht eine Form.
Wenn du jetzt zum Ausgangspunkt zurückkehrst,
wirst du einen kleinen Kreis sehen.
Das heißt, die Form wird geschlossen.
Das ist ganz wichtig,
denn für technische Modezeichnungen wollen wir immer die
Formen schließen.
Später ist das nämlich wichtig,
wenn du zum Beispiel deiner Form eine Farbe geben möchtest
oder diese mit einem bestimmten Stoff ausfüllen möchtest.
Und nur mit geschlossenen Formen ist das problemlos möglich.
Deshalb ist es eine gute Angewohnheit,
die Formen immer zu schließen.
Wenn jetzt deine Form geschlossen hast und wieder auf dein
Plattpapier bist, wirst du merken,
du kannst jetzt gar nicht aus dieser Funktion raus und
zeichnest immer weiter.
Es ist, als ob du einen Stift hast,
den du einfach nicht absetzen kannst.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt nicht mehr weiter zeichnen
möchtest,
solltest du zunächst aus der Funktion Zeichenfeder
wieder rausgehen.
Das kannst du indem du auf ein anderes Werkzeug klickst.
Wir gehen deshalb jetzt zu den Auswahlwerkzeugen,
denn das sind die die ich euch als nächstes
vorstellen möchte.
Als Auswahlwerkzeug haben wir den schwarzen Pfeil,
um gesamte Formen auszuwählen,
oder den weißen Pfeil als Direktauswahlwerkzeug.
Wir gehen jetzt erstmal auf den schwarzen Pfeil.
Damit kannst du wie gesagt,
gesamte Objekte auswählen und verschieben,
vergrößern oder skalieren.
Klick jetzt also mal auf deine Form und du wirst ein paar
Anfasser an den Ecken sehen.
Dann kannst du deine Form auch schon verändern.
Zieh einfach mal daran und du wirst merken,
sie verformt sich, vergrößert sich oder verkleinert sich,
je nachdem was du machst.
Allerdings wirst du auch merken,
dass sie sich gleich etwas verzerrt,
dass also die ursprüngliche Form verändert wird.
Wenn du das jetzt nicht möchtest und die Form an sich
beibehalten möchtest,
drückst du gleichzeitig die Shift-Taste.
Du hältst also die Shift-Taste gedrückt und kannst jetzt
deine Form proportional vergrößern oder verkleinern.
Jetzt schauen wir uns noch das Direktauswahlwerkzeug an.
Damit kannst du einzelne Punkte oder Linien verschieben.
Wenn du auf eine Linie klickst, siehst du,
dass alle Punkte der Form unausgefüllt sind,
also weiß sind.
Und jetzt kannst du auf einen einzelnen Punkt klicken und
der ist jetzt mit der Farbe blau
ausgefüllt.
Und damit weißt du du hast diesen Punkt angewählt.
Jetzt kannst du durch das Halten der Shift-Taste mehrere
Punkte auswählen oder du ziehst einfach von außen über
mehrere Punkte rüber und kannst jetzt einen Teil der Form
transformieren.
Als nächstes zeige ich dir,
wie wir mit der Zeichenfeder Kurven
zeichnen.
Klick jetzt auf dein Plattpapier und es entsteht ein
Punkt.
Und jetzt möchtest du einen zweiten Punkt setzen.
Dazu klickst du wieder und lässt diesmal aber nicht los.
Und jetzt ziehst du gleichzeitig in eine Richtung.
Das kannst du mit der Maus machen oder mit dem Trackpad zum
Beispiel, indem du mit dem Zeigefinger dann einfach in eine
Richtung ziehst oder indem du den Zeigefinger gedrückt
hältst und dann mit dem Mittelfinger in eine Richtung
ziehst.
Finde für dich raus, was da die beste Methode ist.
Und wenn du jetzt in eine Richtung ziehst, wirst du merken,
es entsteht eine Kurve.
Wenn du jetzt loslässt, hast du eine Kurve gezeichnet.
An dieser Kurve befindet sich jetzt eine Tangente und die
gibt die Richtung an, in die du weiterzeichnen kannst.
Wenn du diese Tangente jetzt nicht haben möchtest und frei
weiterzeichnen möchtest,
klickst du einfach nochmal auf den Punkt.
Und jetzt kannst du frei in jede Richtung weiterzeichnen.
Wenn aber jetzt die Tangente von Nutzen ist,
das kann sie auch manchmal sein,
dann behalte sie einfach bei und zeichne weiter und es
entsteht eine weitere Kurve.
Aber denke daran,
geklickt halten und nicht absetzen und in eine Richtung
ziehen, damit es wirklich eine Kurve wird und keine gerade
Linie.
Keine Sorge, wenn das am Anfang nicht gleich klappt.
Das geht wirklich nicht nur dir so.
Es braucht einfach eine gewisse Übung und deswegen kannst du
das Video jetzt hier anhalten und einfach mal ein bisschen
probieren, bis du den Dreh wirklich raus hast.
Wir machen jetzt weiter mit einem Formlöschen.
Wenn du jetzt deine Form die du gezeichnet hast,
löschen möchtest,
musst du erstmal aus der Zeichenfederfunktion rausgehen
und gehst deshalb am besten auf die Werkzeuge zur Auswahl
oder Direktauswahl.
Ich gehe jetzt auf den schwarzen Pfeil und kann damit meine
Form auswählen.
Und wenn ich sie einmal ausgewählt habe,
mit dem schwarzen Pfeil habe ich ja die gesamte Form
ausgewählt,
kann ich jetzt einfach auf die Entfernen oder Delete bzw.
Backspace-Taste drücken, je nach System.
Und schon ist die Form gelöscht.
Falls das jetzt aber ein Fehler war und du die Form gar
nicht löschen wolltest,
kannst du sie natürlich auch ganz leicht wieder zurückholen.
Vielleicht kannst du dich erinnern,
in dem Menü Bearbeiten können wir Dinge rückgängig machen
und gleichzeitig sieht man hier auch die Tastaturkürzel.
Das ist Ctrl oder Command Z,
wie eigentlich in ganz vielen Programmen.
Das ist in Adobe Illustrator nicht anders.
Kannst du damit ganz einfach Schritte zurückgehen.
Und schon ist deine Form wieder da.
Und da wir schon von löschen reden,
können wir jetzt auch gleich mal speichern.
Da es das erste Mal ist,
dass wir unsere Zeichnung speichern,
gehen wir auf das Menü Datei Speichern unter.
Und wenn wir die Form dann einmal gespeichert haben,
können wir natürlich auch ganz normal auf Speichern drücken.
Hier gibt es natürlich auch wieder Tastaturkürzel.
Also Shift, Command oder Ctrl S ist Speichern unter.
Dann können wir hier einen Namen eingeben.
Ich gebe jetzt hier einfach mal Illustrator Einführung
ein.
Drücke auf OK und schon ist meine Datei bespeichert.
Gewöhn dir wirklich an, dann immer mal zwischenzuspeichern,
falls das Programm doch mal abstürzen sollte,
damit du deine Arbeit nicht komplett verloren hast.
Hier nochmal die wichtigsten Punkte als Zusammenfassung.
Wenn du mit der Zeichenfeder arbeitest,
kannst du eine Linie zeichnen,
in dem du klickst und dann nochmal klickst.
Wenn du eine Kurve zeichnest, klickst du einmal
und beim zweiten Klick ziehst du gleichzeitig und ziehst
diese Kurve in die Richtung,
in die du sie haben möchtest und lässt nicht los.
Der schwarze Pfeil wählt gesamte Formeln aus und der
weiße Pfeil wählt einzelne Punkte oder Linien
aus.